most people don't understand how much
actual effort it takes to make something
exceptional it's not about doing your
best it's about doing what's required
whenever I don't want to do something
this is the actual phrase that comes in
my head I will do what's required I look
at some of the old presentations that I
would make for my company and I'm like
embarrassed I remember thinking when I
looked at it this is exceptional at the
time that was probably the best you
could do that's where the [__]
disconnect happens bro you think because
it's the best that you did that it's
[__] great but in reality the market
says nah it's not as good as everybody
else's [__] everything's not as good as
you think it is you might have given it
your best but you didn't do what was
required